die touristen sind wieder zurück in
riccione an der adria-küste genießen das
strandfeeling die italienische dolce
vita urlaub als würde es corona nicht
geben
doch die angst ist immer da
ja die sorge bleibt aber die meisten
leute sind inzwischen geimpft
das risiko ist bestimmt niedriger masken
auch in den geschlossenen lokalen aber
es stimmt schon
die leute halten sich nicht immer dran
deshalb ist impfen das allerwichtigste
baramundi betreibt das strandbad playa
del sol und hat alle hände voll zu tun
das geschäft brummt diesen sommer alles
streng nach corona regeln barbara will
alles richtig machen
diese saison soll auf keinen fall ins
wasser fallen ich zeig dir mal alles
also das hier ist die restaurant mario
wo man frischen fisch essen kann und
einen aperitivo trinken kann
schau dir das strandbad hier an das ist
ja alles an der frischen luft kam sie
wegen corona viel verändert wir haben
die schirme weiter auseinander gestellt
dadurch verlieren wir 30 prozent wie
alle strandbäder aber wir müssen
garantieren dass pro schirm zwölf
quadratmeter fläche vorhanden ist
[Musik]
für sie heißt dass auch ein drittel
weniger liegen und einnahmen die preise
hat sie trotzdem nicht erhöht es
erschien einfach nicht richtig ehrlich
sich in so einem jahr an dieser
situation zu bereichen den gewinn
mitzunehmen
wir haben so viel nachfrage es wäre
einfach aber
bloß nicht die stammgäste verprellen die
schon seit jahren oder jahrzehnten kommt
fast nie familie sind auch viele
deutsche
jesse höpfl kennt das strandbad seit
ihrer kindheit 22 jahre lang kommt sie
schon her
letztes jahr fiel der sommerurlaub
erstmals aus corona bedingt jetzt ist es
wieder wie früher fast also das gefäß
nicht aufgebaut will ich jedes mal muss
ich jetzt halt die ganzen sachen an den
tisch bestellen
und ja in der stadt klar man hat über
eine maske auf aber sonst ja besser als
gedacht also ich bin auch schon deswegen
ich habe überhaupt keine angst mehr und
auch um die anderen games kindern ja
doch so weit ist auch italien noch nicht
56 prozent der gesamtbevölkerung ist
vollständig geimpft abends trainern sich
im zentrum von riccione die touristen
aus allen teilen des landes aus ganz
europa um das wo die hochansteckende
delta variante kursiert das macht vielen
sorgen dass corona trauma sitzt tief das
virus hatte italien im vergangenen jahr
besonders hart getroffen
die italienische regierung sitzt nun
alles aufs impfen auf mobile stationen
an denen man sich spontan impfen lassen
kann im urlaub und auf den greenpeace
die am freitag kommt der impfausweis als
lockmittel
damit können sie in allen bars
restaurants und diskotheken feiern
beatrice eine der ersten die die chance
nutzt um endlich wieder reisen zu können
um die häuser zu ziehen
in unserem alter das mit dem grün passen
ein bisschen zwiespältig aber es bietet
uns einen ausweg aus dieser zeit in der
wir jetzt leben
für die jungen ist das eine große
motivation
man tut was gutes für sich selbst und
dann auch noch für andere schon mit der
ersten impfdosis erhält beatrice den
begehrten greenpeace und damit
freiheiten zurück die einführung dieses
impfnachweis es hat zu einem anstieg der
zuletzt erlernen impfbereitschaft
geführt um durchschnittlich 20 prozent
die helfer sind zufrieden
heute abend waren es viele wünsche ich
wirklich fehler vor allem viele junge
und das ist wichtig denn die jungen sind
die die sich am meisten bewegen die da
hingehen wo es voll ist
sie wollen die pläne der regierung
durchkreuzen
impfgegner protestieren seit wochen den
italienischen städten in rom vergangenes
wochenende sind es ultra rechte gruppen
auf der einen seite er sieht erika und
querdenker auf der anderen
einig sind sie sich alle in ihrem zorn
auf die impf politik der regierung auf
den greenpeace was für eine freiheit
soll das sein
die freiheit in den urlaub zu fahren das
wichtige ist doch die gesundheit und
nicht die freiheit essen zu gehen oder
urlaub zu machen und diese impfung ist
nicht sicher also nicht nehmen oder sie
nehmen uns doch alle unsere freiheit
seit zwei jahren sehen wir dass unsere
verfassung zerfällt und jetzt wollen sie
auch noch diese absolut diskriminierende
regel einführen
sie wollen uns diesen experimentellen
impfstoff aufbauen das ist nicht gerecht
das sind schließlich unsere körper der
widerstand ist erbittert und dass sie
sich nicht impfen lassen wollen
gefährdet was die regierung erreichen
will
in playa del sol sind fast alle
mitarbeiter geimpft sagt barbara ihr
kommt es darauf an weiterarbeiten zu
können
steigende corona infektionszahlen
könnten das erneut verhindern
davor haben sie angst den regionen also
für mich ist das so wenn du diesen job
machst dann von ganzem herzen
mein großvater war schon bademeister wir
sind am meer groß geworden
das ist unser leben und natürlich
brauchst du einen job um zu überleben
und zu leben
es ist tatsächlich so etwas wie ein
überlebenskampf der einen spagat ähnelt
die bevölkerung schützen vor dem
albtraum einer neuen corona welle und
gleichzeitig den tourismus
aufrechterhalten
das will italien erreichen mit einer
impfstrategie die den italienern
freiheit verspricht und normalität